[Music]
do you guys listen to spotify
yeah no i lied i have pandora i'm old oh
i don't know
are we supposed to agree for music i put
music in there you put music in the
spotify
no i type you're the one that puts it in
there no no i i search
i search the music that i want
to play to hear something oh that's that
you're using it correctly
coincidentally big boy you're a big boy
i put
the the name in the box and then it
plays the music
i use youtube i use youtube i always
write best
first i always write best i go best
house
2020 or best funk jams playlist
because i only want to listen to the
best i thought you were putting best
house like you're looking for real
estate
no no no tell us what you're really
thinking about
okay so i'm thinking spotify has a
really great
algorithm the best algorithm do you know
about this algorithm no
okay you just know that it plays music i
hope it's the best because that's true
it does
fulfill his service but they have such a
good algorithm that they are actually
responsible for getting 16 billion
new artist discoveries each month which
means it gets its users to listen to
songs they have never heard before
16 billion times a month i do
exclusively listen to my daily mixes
see i don't actually go into like my own
playlist or whatever
what is this like the bono cd where i
had to listen to the [ __ ] album and i
didn't want to
no yeah so this actually kind of
identifies your taste and
like it does it pretty accurately so
let's say you've been listening to a
bunch of music all month long right
they'll make you six different playlists
of different genres that you have in the
future but what if you want to like
dabble into the unknown
no then yeah well i mean then they have
like other ones that you could go into
like
like uh they have a discover new
category yeah but
yeah it's pretty good at matching your
tastes to the recommendations
so what they're rolling out right now is
a
an option for artists to utilize
if they want to get paid a little bit
less they can be
they can boost their recommendations in
people's
um streams so
you have to listen to a bunch of bad
artists that are like so that's
they have money that's like something
that oh no you don't have to pay for it
they just take a pay cut so normally
they get a fee for when they're pla
in royalty check for when their songs
play in people's uh streams
this is like if you want to boost stores
you just get paid a little bit less
for those songs that get paid so it's
kind of like a win-win yeah it's worth
it i wonder like you don't have to pay
spotify was in the news and stuff and
was really known for paying the artist
so little
like that's why taylor swift hated it so
much i see you weren't paying enough
yeah so what this is for is really to
they are
at least this is what they're pitching
it as is to make it more accessible
for smaller artists to get their music
smaller artists like dusky hunters i
heard they were on spotify
who hmm dusky hunters
[Music]
you're world famous i've never heard of
house music yeah
i thought it was your own band that you
were trying to pronounce i think it is
you haven't picked up on that uh i think
you're missing some heavy cues
the two artists are jan and co jan and
co chad and coke
oh okay yeah you've never heard of them
i have not heard of them but they're
pretty good
one uh one of them comes from this uh
really cool talk show called
rk news and then the other one comes
from this really cool dance crew
called like the doryotics and like
they're really cool
okay what's your favorite song
uh uh uh uh sometimes partying
wrecked just kidding i forgot i i made
these songs like
four years ago that sounds like a good
song for them i i don't even know my own
song titles you just forgot
yeah because i asked you yeah okay i
forgot
to stop me in my tracks i take it i'm
gonna have to be the one to remember
[ __ ] in this relationship
you guys are like a married couple
already
i make him nervous where did i put the
cinnamon honey
so wait so when you listen to the new
artists in your stream you
end up like going and checking them out
and like finding more tracks from them
actually because
i know what i like but i also get tired
of hearing the same songs all the time
so i always use that because i was a big
fan of pandora before
uh before like spotify basically took
over everything yeah um
but yeah i often that's how i find new
artists all the time
you're a proactive listener because i am
just chilling there
and then if i like something i don't
look it up i'm just like oh i like that
i try to google the lyrics i've always
been really like big into finding
artists i don't know
i used to do it the old school way where
like if a song plays in a movie he used
to get really upset with we're not
really upset but we'd be in a movie and
like a song plays and i'm like what song
is that and i pull out shazam
she's the [ __ ] and like she's the
[ __ ] whose phone
lights up
that pissed me off because at the end it
tells you all the songs in the
soundtrack it doesn't
it's not on like it's not speaking and
we went to the arc light because we're
[ __ ] rich
and when we're where you're gonna take
me that happens
people at the arclight feel like they're
entitled to not ever have any
interruptions whatsoever even you go
into the bathroom basically yeah and so
they're all just like
oh really like shut up do this i found
so many good songs that way i know
i would never have not i guess i could
have googled the soundtrack to that
movie after but
i wanted to know right the easiest way
is type in
best songs and the best ones pop up
i [ __ ] up that's what i always do i
don't like spotify's leia i don't like
the colors
it's the black i don't like the black
and the green i don't like it so i don't
use i use
apple and then i go and throw these
songs yes
they'll be like a song i like and then i
go create playlists
it's kind of like pandora genius i'm
sorry who oh apple used to have an
itunes thing called genius playlist
but i don't know if they still have it
oh no i just uh i just clicked on the
three dots and it says create a creative
station
so kind of the same thing i was like i
want to hear stuff like this
i don't feel like looking around give me
my vibe and then i end up
saving those songs so it's like pandora
and spotify kind of
oh yeah yeah it's a spotify would be
like play radio of this song
yeah but i like i'll find a song that i
like and then i'll just create a station
from it and then i'll be on that list
and then like just that song or that
style be like
i want to hear more like that do you
remember when all computers were just
black with green writing
that was a very long matrix
and it's blinking yeah do you guys ever
crave music
and you're like i need that song right
now yes yes but then you only remember
like the sound oh and then you're trying
to like figure out what song that was
that you had stuck
if you do it to alexa i found songs that
way i'd be like how do you do it alexa
what's the song that goes take
my hand and take my whole
you actually got the words and they'll
listen to your melody and know too but
sometimes i don't know the words and i'm
just like yeah
i think the google one you don't even
need the words now what you can kind of
just go
how does it go when what song is that
there'll always be like three lyrics
that i know and i'll just type that in
and i'll find the song
yeah i usually just type it in i only
remember like oh baby it's like
50 million songs come on like if i put
take my hand i would probably like the
song would probably pop up and then i'd
know the rest of the words
what if you're [ __ ] a chick so good
and so hard and you're really machine
gunning that [ __ ]
and then like bombs over baghdad please
because of the moans that she's making
are true that
oh my god go faster oh okay you just
keep going
yeah i really like that song yeah you go
to the song i'd be down with that that's
fine yeah am i the chick that you're
machine gunning oh i would hope so
okay me too yeah machine gun steve yeah
which
although that is very close to a rival
of eminem's um
name and i really don't know well i mean
not these days anymore
yeah it's true he's just punk rock now
which i really am into
he's like emo rock he's dating someone
he's dating
megan megan fox i was like she's dating
someone hot yeah
yeah is he really i didn't know that
yeah but i like his new music a lot
what about brian austin green what about
him they broke up or something yeah
they broke up people don't always stay
together megan fox
yeah i'm so out of the loop they have a
kid and [ __ ] dude they do
what who machine gun kelly no no megan
fox and the captain you just like him
because he has the same
last name as you no i don't even i don't
even remember wait where was he from
90210 or
okay is she still in things i don't know
she's in machine gun kelly right now oh
or he's in her i mean no she's probably
you don't she's dumb
she's very dominant i thought she said
she's tough she's dumb she's
dumb wow damn got some haters over here
so upset yeah so anyway um it will help
a new artist get discovered
and they say that they spotify says that
they're gonna stick to their guns about
like if people don't like the songs
they're hearing
they will stop recommending it they
won't like you can't just boost it and
then it's a shitty song and then they
keep boosting it can you vote like the
song up or down like pandora's
yeah i like that clicking the dots and
be like i don't like this
see less of songs like this or skip i
like that part
i like to skip the only time i used it
is when people share like playlists with
me
you have to check out this new song or
whatever in this like mix
yeah i think i only checked it out for
podcasts
yeah or was it soundcloud probably
spotify i know i know a lot of podcasts
started moving to spotify because that's
how you could get paid outside of
brand-new mm-hmm
otherwise that was the only way you
could get paid for podcasts oh i see
yeah yeah that's what joe rogan went
right yeah well he got a big ass 100
like exclusive brand deal with them i
heard that the number that he got was
like
two times more than what's been
publicized probably i believe it was
more than 100 million
i'm sorry what that's cray cray no
wonder he moved to texas he didn't want
to get taxed on 100 million
13 100 giving away 13 million dollars
about to go up to 16
oh my jesus wow
good thing i don't make that much same
dude you know all those memes coming out
where it's like
all these people that are worried about
tax plans if your ceiling looks like
a popcorn ceiling yeah we don't have to
worry about it we're okay
yeah also there's a we're gonna move
into a van if your net worth is more
than 30 million
you get taxed like four percent just for
that just because you make more than
that just because your net worth is more
than 30 million
yeah well we don't have to worry about
that over here
yeah but we're american so we always
think that we're going to have to worry
about that
because we think one day that's going to
be us right yeah yeah yeah that's how
that goes we're going to get to 29
29 million and you just have to stop
yeah you cannot right at 29 i'm gonna be
like oh
there's a guy right now playing
scratchers who's like wait i don't want
to get if i
if i make 30 billion give me the other
one
yeah [ __ ] that 10 million on that one i
got this i'm taking that one
tell me i'm wrong you're not that's
what's happening
yeah favorite song of all time oh man
purple rain
that's your favorite favorite song of
all yeah yeah i can go hard on purple
randy
he got mad because they didn't play it
at our wedding i actually was upset
really what is it about purple rain dude
it's a downer song it's about a guy who
doesn't want to be a weekend lover dude
he wants to [ __ ] have some real [ __ ]
so the groom went up to dj and was like
play the song and then did you said
no you don't get to have this song it's
not this is your special day
but this is my special dj that's nice
you got wi-fi [ __ ] put up on youtube i
could do that right now wait they didn't
have purple rain
a dj didn't have purple rain maybe it's
not a wedding song it's not really a
wedding
but it was the end of the night it's
very sad why does everyone's like a
dominant no it's not it's
you gotta listen to the whole [ __ ]
song you never did yeah
she never wants the airport every time i
turn up her in the car she's like
no no that's not true he has five songs
on his phone and i'm sick of it
what are the five songs he has a brain
out of the sun i've been doing just five
minutes
because instagram story years ago and i
had to download that for it
stuff with that that one is annoying i
like that song
too but i used to like it too much okay
song number three
i don't know on the list of five i
literally don't know
i've stopped
[Music]
[Music]
you